ce dernier jour de nombreux articles
sont apparues au sujet d'une compagnie
air et anna et des doutes qui existe
autour de cette jeune entreprise qui a
créé le trouble chez de nombreux
internautes et journalistes
mais alors de quoi s'agit-il exactement
tout commence le 1er mars dernier quand
deux jeunes entrepreneurs décide de
lancer une société qui s'apparente à une
compagnie aérienne
cette société présentée comme une jeune
compagnie aérienne qui cassent les prix
à paris une première fois aux yeux du
grand public dans le clip de vita et
slimane visionner plus de six millions
de fois si cette compagnie aérienne est
au coeur de l'actualité
c'est parce que le 21 septembre dernier
cyril hanouna offert à tout le public de
la grande d'arc à des voyages organisés
par cette société à ses jours en grèce
pour supprimer quelques jours plus tard
c'est le public présent dans le studio
de tpm paix qui a remporté un voyage à
marrakech via cette même compagnie très
vite deux premiers soupçons apparaissent
après certaines recherches certains
affirment même que les vols annoncés
n'existe pas face à ces accusations
l'entreprise en question s'explique il
n'y a pas encore eu de vol
on les a mis sur notre site car ce sont
des vols qu'on prévoit de faire plus
tard pour attirer les clients
mais on ne peut pas les réserver en
réalité cette compagnie aérienne n'en
serait pas une mais une entreprise de
services aériens une jeune société
fondée il ya six mois par deux jeunes
entrepreneurs grâce à une levée de fonds
nous louons des avions nous vendons les
places et ensuite nous affrétons les
avions en fonction de la demande
si aujourd'hui la compagnie n'a encore
réalisé aucun vol officiellement il
assure que ce n'est pas une arnaque les
différents problèmes rencontrés par les
internautes sur le site serait dû à un
bug technique en raison de la trop
grosse affluence soudaine ce qui aurait
bloqué toute possibilité de réservation
à ce jour un seul client aurait acheté
un billet pour new york et il aurait
reçu sa convocation ce soir les deux
créateurs de cette société sont sur
notre plateau pour s'expliquer
alors finalement il n'y en a qu'un c'est
ryan
bonsoir ryan alors vous vous présentez
comme le pdg de la compagnie vous avez
23 en est on avec nous bernard sabbah
merci spécial voyage merci bernard vous
allez nous éclairer sur cette affaire et
lionel stan qui êtes-vous mais bon soir
c'est avec cyril hanouna directeur
général d'ashoka suivi la faire tout le
week-end pour quoi on a suivi cette
affaire
bien entendu sachez le déjà je tiens à
dire toutes les personnes qui ont gagné
un voyage chez nous bien sûr on les fera
partir voilà quoi qu'il arrive avec le
nice et si vous pouvez nous dire ans et
sur le ce qu'ont gagné le voyage en
grèce partiront en grèce et le jour de
votre anniversaire c'était au maroc et
partiront tous au maroc c'était pour le
public m'aime moi avec isabelle
morini-bosc aussi avec isabelle voir
quelle que soit la compagnie telle que
celle là comme partout moi c'est une
gêne au delà de ça c'est si on a pu
tromper des personnes qui ont acheté des
billets et qui sont faits voilà arnaquer
voilà donc ça c'est ce qu'on va voir
parce que est ce qu'il ya un hack ou pas
est-ce que cette compagnie existe ou pas
alors on a plein de questions à poser à
ryan alors on va revenir en détail sur
ce partenariat
vous allez nous expliquer et nous dire
toute la vérité parce que je veux que
les téléspectateurs sachent la vérité ce
soit nous aussi on cherche la vérité
on a entendu plein de choses là dessus
donc ce soir on a envie voilà de savoir
ce qui s'est réellement passé ce qui ce
qui voilà alors vous avez créé cette
société en mars dernier vous êtes avec
un autre associé qui est mineur donc
c'est sa mère qui signe les papiers avec
lui le capital de la société est de 1
euro s'agit d'une société de services
aériens avec un bureau basé à lyon la
société mère de la compagnie sera en
cours d'immatriculation en irlande tout
un ferla et la société n'a jamais encore
effectuer de vols
je vais vous demander avant toute chose
avant de démarrer les explications qu'on
n'est pas là ici pour faire de la
promotion pour voilà votre marque donc
je ne veux plus qu'on cite la marque
pour l'instant voilà donc on ne cite pas
la marque de cette compagnie ou de cette
prétendue compagnie ma première question
c'est mine de rien je vous le dis on a
eu très vite des soupçons parce que déjà
vous n'êtes pas une compagnie aérienne a
légalement ainsi pour la dg assénant
alors pour la dg à celle de la diode
générale de l'aviation civile louis qui
ont dit qu'on était un courtier aérien
juridiquement on a pu faire vérifier par
nos avocats que c'est bien une compagnie
aérienne on n'a pas de code iata
comme toutes les compagnies c'est un
code qui est obligatoire pour faire des
vols public
on n'a pas de certificat de transport
aérien cependant comme nous parce qu'on
n'a pas de propre flotte à nous on n'a
pas de nos avions mais vous n'avez
jamais fait de vol pour l'instant pour
l'instant alors je vous dis parce que il
ya plusieurs internautes et journalistes
ont remarqué des éléments troublants
premiers éléments la création récente de
la compagnie créée en mars dernier avec
un capital de seulement 1 euro
comme on peut le voir sur le site de
societe.com second élément votre site
internet compte tenu des fautes
d'orthographe comme le remarque et
certains internautes
florent 2 rue florent de rue notamment
notamment voilà florent qui est un
intérieur qui a été très actif sur cette
affaire voilà troisième élément les
photos utilisées comme moyen de
communication parce qu'elle est par
votre home compagnies sont en réalité
des photos retouchées d'avion de la
compagnie air berlin
ça pouvait nous dire ça c'est ça c'est
au cc retouchée oui tout à fait oui mais
donc là il ya quand même les yaris de la
communication oui mais c'est la
boucherie
comme il est question c'est la publicité
c'est de la publicité mensongère ça ça
sert semble pas non c'est un peu chacun
de voir comme il veut mais c'est de la
communication
si vous n'avez pas d'avion on n'a pas
d'avion mais justement dans les projets
de l'entreprise sur du long terme ce
sera des avions qui seront exactement
identiquement à ce design la wii dans
les projets moi aussi j'ai des projets
peut-être de changer le plateau voilà on
va pas on va tu veux pas juger par les
photos si vous voulez trième éléments
certains des vols affichés sur votre
site n'existe pas vous nous dites qu'ils
sont affichés pour des raisons de
marketing
ils ne sont pas ouverts à la réservation
tout à fait alors bernard sabbah avant
qu'on ait les explications de ce
monsieur vous vous dites moi en tant que
spécialiste du voyage
écoutez moi je n'ai rien contre vous je
vous mettre à l'aise je ne suis pas
avocat je suis médiateur dans l'émission
de julien courbet le matin à la radio je
ne comprends pas votre méthodologie de
vente aujourd'hui vous vendez parce que
vous n'avez pas d'accord n'est pas le
grand écho nous ne volons d'aidé parce
que vous n'avez pas parce que les avait
pas encore acheté ailleurs vous avez pas
nous l'avions vous l'avez pas louer
c'était encore d'accord donc ça veut
dire qu'aujourd'hui je m'appelle bernard
sabbah je veux prendre un vol pour aller
à berlin
je vais vous achetez un paris berlin
pour partir donc le 17 décembre rentré
le 24 décembre vous allez me vendre je
vais vous aller encaisser ça allait
encaisser 1 à lyon vous allez bien
encaissé 317 euros
d'accord jusque là tout va bien et vous
allez envoyer quoi un world quand vous
avez fait pour le client qui s'appelle
rachid avec marc est donc un numéro de
vol qui n'existe pas donc vous allez
espérer acheter en dernière minute chez
quelqu'un qui aurait de la dispo c'est
pas un numéro de vol qui est affichée
c'est un identifiant de vol c'est
différent le numéro de vol vous l'avez
48 heures à l'avancé avant le vol vous
savez qu'en france c'est totalement
interdit d'avoir justement une
information qui est erroné chaque
consommateur voyageurs qui achètent un
billet d'avion d'accord dans une agence
de voyages aux compagnies aériennes sur
un site internet doit exactement
connaître le numéro de vol sont heures
de décollage
son heure d'arrivée et si toutefois je
lui dis bien à tous les téléspectateurs
si toutefois on vous change le nom de la
compagnie vous avez le droit d'annuler
sans frais et de vous retourner contre
l' agence de voyage ou la compagnie
aérienne en question dont vous voyez
quand même que c'est quand même un tout
petit peu léger et pourtant je le répète
je n'ai rien quand votre structure
mais je suis surpris de votre
méthodologie une fois de plus alors que
neil stein on en est où dans cette
affaire après on va voir quel est le
quai ce qu'est ce que vous proposez
parce que mine de rien on comprend pas
en fait quel est votre business plan
quel est votre voilà qu'est ce qu'est ce
que vous voulez faire en fait alors
lionel alors dans cette affaire pour la
personne qui a réservé ce biais pour new
york
niall avons eu parce que mine de rien
après la publicité vous l'avez il ya une
personne
il ya demandé un billet pour new york
lors new york qui l'a acheté vous l'avez
encaissé lui a porté plainte et quelques
heures après elle a reçu cette
convocation sans vraiment elle est
actuellement l'antenne sans sur le bar
cause sans vraiment numéro 2 bis je peux
maintenant c'est fait on a je veux
qu'ils sachent et sachets on en a parlé
ensemble que puisque tout est bloqué sur
votre site
vous devez lui fournir un billet donc
vous allez lui acheter un billet sur une
autre compagnie pour que cette personne
puisse partir la petite façon de
contourner le règlement tel que le
l'époque monsieur ça nous on est
d'accord alors la voilà aujourd'hui ce
que vous faites ça veut dire vous
trouvez des palais le 20 mars à bas est
ce que vous connaissez ce cas de figure
qu'est ce qui s'est passé en fait
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont voulu faire donc
moi je vais vous dire concrètement ce
que je pense mais je ne peux me tromper
une fois de plus je pense qu'ils ont une
idée géniale ses deux garçons d'accord
gérant à 17 ans c'est quand même assez
exceptionnel donc de dette aussi
créatifs sont des génies qui se dit
comment va commercialiser des billets on
sait qu'aujourd'hui des vols sont vides
alors qu'est ce qu'on va faire on va
commercialiser des billets des
destinations et puis après on verra tout
ce qu'on aura encaissé comme argent
mais pas question qui ne le rend pas
l'argent et ils vont acheter au fur et à
mesure des places qui vont se libérer de
dernière minute et ils vont proposer
donc évidemment le 17 mars le 18 mars
selon la dispo et s'ils n'ont pas la
bonne date ils proposeront une autre
date
en espérant évidemment que le client
soit d'accord voilà ce qu on pourrait
supposer à sassari pas de mots c'est pas
du tout ça alors interdite nous nous si
vous voulez on part sur un avion vide
c'est-à-dire ont loué un avion vide en
che on le remplit de passagers et
l'avion décolle ensuite mais on ne vend
pas des places de d'autres compagnies
aériennes pour l'instant je dis bien je
le répète de à tous les téléspectateurs
pour l'instant parce que comme ça et mon
métier c'est depuis 35 ans que je fais
ça d'accord j'étais distributeurs
producteurs dont vous inquiétez pas je
connais parfaitement ce métier là j'ai
même affrété des avions pour une équipe
de football très connu pendant des
années d'accord on peut pas se tromper
là dessus quand avion n'est pas remplies
et qu'il est rempli à 40%
monsieur non on perd de l'argent et
beaucoup d'argent alors qu'est ce qu'on
fait dans ces cas-là on régule en
réguler ça veut dire quoi
on prend les gens qu'on avait acquis en
avant du cps là et on met trois
personnes sur le vol d air berlin on met
trois personnes sur le vol d'air france
ont messi personne sur le banc de deux
norvégiennes
on met toutes les compagnies on se
débrouille mieux qu'on peut c'est un
métier un petit peu différent ce qui est
très étonnant cyril j'ai eu des
institutions officielles
ce nouveau métier de louer des avions
pour les remplir on peut tous le faire
ce n'est pas réglementée en france comme
vous allez louer une voiture
on peut louer en herbe escudé plainte
contre monsieur non il ya eu juste ce
biais pour new york pour l'instant les
braises qui a eu des plaintes une
plainte mais il ya une plainte une
plainte de deux passagers qui le new
york et qui a vu finalement son billet
il ya un son bien et que cette personne
va partir cette personne bien sûr
partira mais d'après le monde je
confirme ce fait c'est le contraire je
ne confirme pas il ya eu aucune plainte
et aucune enquête n'a été ouverte
justement parce qu'aucune plainte n'a
été déposée pour escroquerie ou pour un
voyageur d'escroquerie pour l'instant
vous électro les par la dgccrf qui l'a
renversée dans des fraudes qui va venir
voir ce que vous faites exactement pour
réglementer ça et surtout pour avertir
les clients car je vous rappelle cyril
et c'est important qu'aujourd'hui avec
le dépôt de bilan de aigle azur des xl
airways le week-end dernier thomascook
un des plus gros opérateurs mons et le
deuxième au mans
là il ya quand même une 89 à avion qui
sont bloqués au sol aujourd'hui les
enjeux sont terribles donc on peut pas
s'amuser avec les clients et moi je
défends ma profession d'accord alors
pour moi important pour dise la vérité
ce soir bien sûr alors vous c'était quoi
votre volonté vouliez faire quoi
compagnies aériennes mais n'avait pas de
compagne ans il n'est pas d'argent c'est
qu'il n'ya pas d'avion compagnies
aériennes en louant est en dessous des
exploitants et les avions de compagnies
ou en tout cas de comme la d'avion qui
sont ré bloqué au sol et ça et bien sûr
le sous-exploitation alors les licences
et les réglementent avez vous pouvez
bruit sourd vous ai fait quelques
quelques erreurs en communication tout à
fait c'est quoi les héros vous avez fait
en a disons que comme un avion tout
blanc et pas très joli on a utilisé donc
des avions d'une ancienne compagne qui a
fermé qui pour nous sera notre prochain
en prime on a encore notre logo de l'est
mais mais mais dites moi mais quand on
voit qu avant quand on voit que les vols
n'existe pas chez certains n'existent
pas pas c'est comme être un fou comment
on peut utiliser le logo d'une compagnie
ce manque est disparue qui a déposé le
bilan de s'en servir pour mettre un
nouveau nom d'une compagnie aérienne qui
n'existe pas vous l'avez dit vous-même
cette compagnie que vous évoquez il
n'existe pas et n'existera jamais quant
à bord quand vous prenez compagnie telle
qu'elle est notée n'existera jamais il
ya aucune différence quand vous prenez
l'avion monsieur est ce que vous avez
les fonds pour faire ce que vous posiez
donc toi vous comme le magnéto l'a dit à
des levées de fond derrière on a
plusieurs investisseurs tout et tout est
en règle et on attend en effet mais pour
l'instant vous n'avez eu aucun client
depuis six bambins en fait si vous
voulez c'est pour ça que l'escroquerie
ça fait un peu rire bien pas
d'escroquerie pas vous mais les gens sur
internet brise et arnaque parce que
justement lorsqu'il ya eu ces deux
émissions là le site était en
maintenance déjà quand il ya eu les deux
émissions alors le way la grosse bêtise
sur le site c'est là que vous allez bien
sûr on voit un numéro de vol qui
n'existait pas un horaire année j'en
fais quoi j'ai appelé charles de gaulle
j'ai appelé la direction de la douane on
n'y a pas d'avion qui part à new york
elle ne vendra qu'ils aient parlé à
reiser pourquoi et vous avez utilisé des
logos différents médias vous aimez ici
paris oups tpm pc huit tf1 voilà alors
vous avez contacté début septembre le
service partenariat de h2o parce que
j'aimerais qu'on explique à nos
téléspectateurs comment ça s'est passé
pour proposer d'offrir des voyages via
votre compagnie entre guillemets en
échange de visibilité c'est ça voilà
donc c'est très réglementé s'esquisser
valente est bon on les avait vus dans le
clip de vitesse lyman a vu plus de six
millions de fois donc il est très très
présent à l'antenne
c'est une agence de com qui nous a
soufflé votre nom aucun autre service
partenariat cyril on offre un peu près
pour plus d'un million d'euros de
cadeaux chaque année encore une saison
de tpm p à partir de là pour que vous
puissiez citer la marque vous savez que
vous ne citez jamais les marques des
cadeaux on s'est adressé à ses 8 on leur
a dit voilà on a la possibilité d'avoir
des voyages est ce que vous acceptez
vous ces huit d'avoir un partenariat
avec eux pour que ses rimes plus les
cités et c'est ce qui s'est passé on a
donc un partenariat avec eux ces 8es h2o
d'accord oui bernard juste un point
l'objet social de votre société à 1 euro
en france je le lis quand même pour tous
les téléspectateurs et les personnes qui
sont ici l'objet social ces sociétés de
marketing qui gère les uniformes du
personnel de compagnies aériennes
formation du management dans marketing
gestion du personnel catherine des
compagnies aériennes ou et aujourd'hui
ce métier que vous faites mais cela
n'est qu'un gérant il ya 17 ans je
voudrais juste mais là je n'en ai rien à
voir dans l'histoire mais je ne veux pas
juste la question
le prix social et celle justement c'est
ce qu'on fait pour toutes les compagnies
de manger un opérateur qui me dit j'ai
deux avions cloués au sol
j'aimerais les faire voler on s'occupe
du marketing on s'occupe de tout chez
moi moi moi ce dont ceux dont je vous
dis ce dont j'ai eu peur et ce dont j'ai
toujours peur je vous dis la vérité
j'aimerais que nous dit la vérité soit
moi je me suis dit c'est peut-être des
petits malins ils sont dit on va créer
une fausse compagnie aérienne on va
prendre beaucoup d'argent et beaucoup de
réservations l'a jamais envoyé les
billets et on va se marrer avec l'argent
sale à terminer et voilà et plus jamais
personne ne nous verra
est ce que c'est c'est bien la preuve
que non je suis là déjà ce soir le
directeur général zakaria est aussi en
coulisses derrière votre projet pour
vous y croyez réalisation mais on l'a
fait dire qu'il ya eu déjà eu des dons
qu'il ya eu des 10 des vices de forme
des relais dans la colocation
communication et des vices de forme de
la communication mais vous dites tous
les gens qui ont qui vont peut-être un
jour réservé leurs billets vont partir
bien sûr vous assurez on l'a fait
vérifié par les avocats d'âge deux eaux
pendants ça fait trois jours qu'on
travaillait pour ça parce que parce que
vous pouvez pas un hacker décidée pour
des gens les pauvres gens qui peuvent
qu'y disent tiens on a des prix
incroyables sur l'évier moi j'ai eu
plein de j'ai vu plein de gens pendant
les réseaux sociaux qui ont qui ont
réagi ce week-end qui sait vous est pas
possible
voila voila sinon mes sacs pour que pour
qu'ils nous on est une référence
et mine de rien ils se disent ne peut
pas on peut pas tromper les gens comme
ça donc sachez que j'étais extrêmement
énervé ce week-end des soupçons qui
portait sur vous parce qu'on peut pas
tromper les gens
voilà aujourd'hui la plein de gens qui
sont dans la galère pour ça que je vois
là vous essayez d'être aussi de vous en
sortir bossi en faisant votre compagnie
à plein de gens qui sont en galère qui
ont envie aussi de partir en vacances
est pour ça qu on doive plein de cadeaux
ici parce qu'on a envie aussi de faire
qui fait tout le monde on essaie de
trouver les meilleurs compromis pour
essayer voilà de de faire plaisir au
maximum de gens et quand je vois des
mecs qui servent de ça pour faire des
arnaques
alors j'espère que ce n'est pas le cas
et c'est ce que vous dites que ce n'est
pas le cas dont on la voit là le même
mais je vous dis ça c'est dégueulasse
voilà donc j'espère que ça c'est pas ça
mais bernard sabbah je vais vous laisser
la parole après vous allez me dire
est-ce que c'est légal ou pas ce qu'ils
sont en train de faire est ce que vous
pensez que les gens qui vont commander
des billets ce qui vont partir ou pas
ils partiront d'accord encore
négativement à la date qu'il souhaite
parce que l'accord quand on affrète a
c'est vrai ça mais c'est une certitude
accord d'accord ainsi prenez le 17
décembre 24 décembre et que vous n'aurez
avec noël bien sûr dans ce qu'ils auront
commercialisés je les mets au défi à 317
euros de commercialiser des vols sur
certaines villes qui seront déjà
conscient comment on peut être aussi
pour les téléspectateurs
il travaille à des compagnies que je
connais et que je côtoie je vais en
citer au moins trois air charter air
france et et autres ces compagnies là
qui sont rois alors vous avez les osc et
moi je compterai mal c'est ma femme
avait déjà avoué sa écoutez moi juste
avoir un problème si tu es donc des
compagnies moi je connais très bien
cette compagnie aérienne hong la frette
on la réserve on verse un acompte d'un
bloc l'avion d'accélérer faire ça toutes
les semaines je sur toutes les semaines
aurait les moyens de pouvoir affréter un
avion vous ai commencé l'affrètement
d'un la gorge et parce qu'on est jeune
on n'a pas d'argent monsieur sait
combien la très belle impression sait
combien la fed ces combats dix mille
euros de l'heure un ami laurent davion
vous fumez euros de l'heure
l'affrètement d'un avion
oui eric naulleau mais si c'est pas une
arnaque est ce que vous seriez d'accord
pour dire que c'est une tromperie dire
que les gens n'achètent pas ce qu'il
croit acheter mes six mois quand
j'achète un virus et face à que j'achète
nous arrache eh bien monsieur j'achète
un horaire numéro deux après un numéro 2
nous siégeons moi j'achète monsieur nan
horaires une certitude de partis
nationaux là il ya pas de vous écouter
ce que dit monsieur ça va parce que ce
monsieur dit moi je vous confirme que
vous prenez aujourd'hui un billet sur
skyline vous partez à l'heure que c'est
indiqué vous partez dans un avion dans
le vol n'existe pas alors pourquoi
depuis six mois des années pas fait
partir une seule personne reste à moi
mais parce que la compagnie vient
d'ouvrir monsieur l'abbé six mois puis
six mois du vote suisse il ya eu quoi
depuis six mois cette année des stages
c'est la déclaration juridique de
l'entrée quand vous avez ouvert qu'on
l'a la semaine dernière la semaine la
semaine dernière citant maintenant c'est
vrai dans les émissions concrètement moi
j'ai vu moi je moi je veut de moi je
partir de lundi je partir à new york
l'anil à la nantaise l'instant il n'y a
pas pensé à démissionner s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît beaucoup
donc ya pas donc il faut que je parte à
une date que vous allez me proposer oui
tout voilà d'accord d'accord ils vont
donc proposer et on n'a pas 70 mille
vols par mois non plus justement parce
qu'il faut qu'on les rende sauf que ce
qu'est ce que vous est présentée aux
gens est ce qu'on nous on a tous compris
ici y compris
cyril et tous ceux qui ont parlé c'est
qu'on pouvait choisir tradition quand je
prends un billet air france british
airways ou air canada j'achète une
compagnie et oui mais alors d'où
l'importance et règle bernard sabbah non
parce que moi ce que je savais c'est
donc yarn à coude à parnac il n'ya pas
arnaque pour l'instant il ya suspicion
il ya beaucoup de doutes la dgse serait
quoi larnaca lent aujourd'hui c'est de
commercialiser des vols parce que l'on
dit carrément aujourd'hui on
commercialise des vols pour appâter des
clients d'accord mais on n'a pas les
places c'est clair quand même comme
message si mais c'est bon ça peut
arriver mais dans la gueule
ça me révulse discussions à doha mais
surtout les gentils je suis sûr que
c'est pas des voyous des bandits de
grand chemin mais ils font n'importe
quoi voilà d'accord donc pour vous c'est
voilà alors moins en externe
comment c'est arrivé ici comme on l'a
fait le partenariat comment ça c'est
passé juste voilà comment comment on a
pu alors quand je voulais dit c'est
vraiment une agence de com qui nous a
dit voilà une nouvelle compagnie qui est
très offensé nous c'est impossible de
vérifier mais le coc bat quand on a fait
notre première vérification
effectivement tout était dans les règles
ils ont le droit c'est un métier qui
existe j'ai appelé la direction générale
d'aviation civile ils m'ont dit tout à
fait vous pouvez louer un avion on peut
partir vous louer un avion vous
commercialisez les places et vous partez
avec le seul problème je l'a posé la
question je réserve
vous l'avez loué l'avion si l'avion
n'est pas plein jeu au sol comment ça se
passe justement s'il ya plus de 70 %
c'est notre politique s'il ya un taux de
remplissage de plus de 70% l'avion par
dans tous les cas inférieur mans ce qui
n'est normalement pas prévu d'arriver
l'avion serait annulé les personnes
partent quand même et une indemnisation
des assurances à hauteur de 600 euros
par vol mais qui sont bien fournis
l'heure qu'il est tout seul il va pas
partir alors oui j'ai vu disons qu'avec
le bad buzz qui a eu ça va être
peut-être un peu difficile mais il sera
redirigé chez notre compagnie à la même
mourir et il sera indemnisé surtout de
600 euros ce qui lui permettra peut-être
de payer l'hôtel accessoires série c'est
très important ce qu'il dit et il faut
la maintenant parler de droit et ça
c'est important
je vous rappelle quand même que les
indemnités dès aujourd'hui des
directives européennes c'est quand on
fait un vol de moins de 1500 km tout à
fait 250 euros pénalité pour la
compagnie si on fait un vol entre mille
5 et 3 8 5 c 4 100 euros et si on fait
un vol là haut de la ccisom vous allez
donner 600 euros à un client parce que
c'est pourquoi vous êtes donné 600 euros
comme ça vous avez évoqué ce chiffre la
500 euros pour vraiment une indemnité
pour new york parce que la c1 par une
nuit leur accorde ça dérape les 1500 m
c'est avec sa porte avant de s'offrir un
avion en trois semaines mais comme on
est un tout et avec les moyens de
communication parce qu'on en a discuté
avant moyens la wii vous est vrai que
j'en fais alors lionel stan est ce qu'il
ya des gens qui votent à renâcler si on
veut savoir sk des gens qui n'ont pas
qui est qui ont pris des billets qui ne
sont pas partis sinon on voit ça
aujourd'hui
non c'est clair que vous alliez l'a déjà
la direction générale de l'aviation
civile que vous avez eue au téléphone
ce n'est pas une compagnie il ne porte
pas plainte contre vous parce que
effectivement il n'y a pas eu d' arnaque
personne est resté cloué au sein d'accor
d'eau pour l'instant il ya peu une
arnaque il y a
sk une perte à ce cas des personnes qui
ont perdu de l'argent à cause de ces
n'ont pas ni personne personne d'accord
alors d'aujourd'hui alors à suivre le
dossier avec bernard il faut le suivre
je serai là bas très bien accompagné on
voulait on espère vous avez mieux
compris ce qui s'est passé en tout cas
c'est vrai que les médias se sont jetés
là dessus comme des fous voilà on
viendra demain à tuer d'ailleurs ce sera
oui ils se sont jetés sur la ferme et
sur moi alors j'ai lu des titres
regardez il ya des articles très factuel
comme 20 minutes
voilà qui disent voilà si rihanna s'est
fait avoir la compagnie aérienne sponsor
est une arnaque alors vous allez
attaquer les gens qui disent c'est une
arnaque ça donc 20 minutes l'attaqué a
écrit d'ailleurs sur le site voilà la
dépêche.fr eux mais eux bon à la victime
thierry vandal convoque les représentent
il ya hélas le parisien comme d'habitude
le parisien qui fait un truc juste pour
déclic la compagnie aérienne partenaire
de cyril hanouna est elle une arnaque
donc voilà donc c'était pas ça qu'on
voulait mais c'était un autre truc voilà
l ombre est avec moi donc avec le truc
comme ça
il ya également même la fp alors l'
agence france-presse café voilà un gars
fait qu'elle ait fait un premier article
regardez l'agencé france presse et
regardons que voilà à charge et après
ils ont rectifié soupçonné l'aviation
civile sur une compagnie aérienne vanté
par anne la voilà donc l' agence
france-presse qui sont supposés être
sérieuse et vous savez ce que nous aura
pendu l'agencé france presse quand on
leur a dit mais j'ai jamais vanté la
compagnie aérienne prométhée nous sommes
et non parce que ça fait du clic bravo
c'est chaud jure que c'est vrai c'est ça
on l'a dit le journaliste de l afp
il en fait partie aussi merci au delà de
ça ce qui est encore plus grave on va
dire c'est au niveau de la presse et le
fait qu'ils aient pas d'organe de presse
on a répondu toute la journée à des
entretiens avec des journalistes on a
dit blanc je vous jure ils ont écrit
noir
écoutez moi je l'espère en tout cas on
va suivre cette affaire on espère que ça
n'est pas un jeu une arnaque ce que tous
les gagnants partiront évidemment une
autre compagne et par quoi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]